le gouvernement arbitre entre la
réduction de la circulation du virus est
le maintien d'une activité économique et
social le choix qu'il a faits impliquent
que la réduction l'assocation du virus
sera plus faible qu'au printemps et donc
en aucun cas il ne faut dire que dans 4
semaines nous pourrons sortir
complètement du confinement
ce serait un monfils et minimum six
semaines huit semaines de confinement
vous regarder les courbes et l'objectif
qu'a fixé chef de l'état qui est de
revenir à 5000 cas détectés par jour en
espérant que cette fois ci la stratégie
tc tracé au lait sera malheur neuf
autour de 40 milles alors qu'on essaie
ça entre quarante cinquante mille et
donc probablement beaucoup plus de
nouveaux cas et bien ce qu'on regarde
les courses ce n'est pas possible
d'atteindre cet objectif là dans un
délai aux autres pourquoi le
gouvernement passe de seulement 1 mois
de parce que sans arrêt court après le
virus parce que sans arrêt il est il
faut le dire dans un arbitrage difficile
entre encore une fois l'activité
économique et la santé mais il faut
comprendre qu'on ne doit pas opposer les
deux plus on laisse le virus circule et
plus les conséquences sont dramatiques
en termes sanitaires mais plus
l'économie sera aussi impactés donc dans
un cas si on laisse circuler on perd sur
les deux tableaux dont l'autre cas c'est
très dur pour l'économie mais on protège
les français on évite des morts qui
serait extrêmement élevé sinon le
gouvernement parle beaucoup de cette
acceptation sociale
mais pour vous il faut dire la vérité
aux français en disant attendait ça va
durer encore six mois donc là on fait
quatre semaines de confinement mais
après ce sera peint déconfinement comme
on l'a connu en mai dernier sur il faut
dire la vérité aux français parce que
l'acceptation sociale elle est liée à
quoi elle et elle est profondément liée
aux liens de confiance entre un peuple
et ses gouvernants et quand vous ne
dites pas la vérité au peuple aux
français et bien après ne vous croient
plus et il n'y a plus d' acceptation ni
sociale ni politique
et combien d'audience qui sont opposés à
ceux qui seraient tentés de ne pas
respecter ces restrictions aujourd'hui
ah mais vous savez l'individualisme est
une valeur solidement ancrée
malheureusement dans notre société ne
pas respecter une mesure qui est fait
pour nous protéger collectivement et
protéger les plus
vulnérables d'entre nous parce que c'est
pas à votre âge quand en bonne santé
qu'on va décéder du coc vide mais ce
sont les plus âgés ce sont ceux qui ont
des maladies chroniques
ce sont ceux qui sont vulnérables refusé
d'appliquer ces mesures s'est refusé de
leur accorder notre protection quelques
mots vous êtes sénateur vous êtes aussi
médecin qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète le
plus aussi en tant que comme de gauche
la question sociale la question
sanitaire aujourd'hui mais les deux sont
liés et les trois sont liées parce que
c'est lié à la question économique mais
nous avons un pays qui est en grande
souffrance et ce qui m'inquiète
peut-être c'est cette incapacité du
gouvernement à se projeter suffisamment
loin dans l'avenir et donc à donner de
l'espoir parce que c'est vrai qu'on peut
pas rester dans cette situation ou sans
arrêt on après sur la tête des gens une
épidémie on y fait face ensemble ou
sinon on y fait très mal face